اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من رفح جنوب قطاع
غزه اهلا بكم اكثر من 100 شهيدا في قصف
اسرائيلي متواصل على قطاع غزه وجثامين
شهداء وعشرات الجرحى يصلون الى مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح واستشهاد
العشرات بينهم اطفال في خانيونس جنوبي
القطاع وثلاثه شهداء في غاره اسرائيليه
استهدفت سياره مدنيه في رفع
جيش الاحتلال يعلن اصابه 19 جنديا خلال
المعارك الجاريه في غزه اشتباكات عنيفه
بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال
جنوب شرق خانيونس القسام تؤكد تدميرها
دبابتين وناقله جند وجراف اسرائيليه في
المغازي والبريج وسرايا القدس تقول انها
قصفت تجمعات لجنود الاحتلال ومستشفى
سوروكا الاسرائيلي يقول انه استقبل ثمانيه
جنود صيب في معارك
غزه بعد تاكيد نتنياهو ان الحرب لن تتوقف
قبل تحقيق اهدافها مصادر اسرائيليه تؤكد
ان بلينكن سيطلب من نتنياهو الانتقال
للمرحله الثالثه والسماح للنازحين بالعوده
الى شمالي القطاع وبن غفير يقول ان مجلس
الحرب غير مفوض باعلان الانتقال الى مرحله
عمليات محدوده في الحرب وان اسرائيل لن
تنتصر بتلك الط
وسط تصعيد اسرائيلي متواصل في الضفه
الغربيه قوات الاحتلال تنفذ حمله اقتحامات
في محيط بلدات بق القيل ونابلس وبيت لحم
وتعتقل 40 فلسطينيا بينهم اسرى سابقون
بمناطق متفرقه من الضفه الى
اللقاء